you're insolent because you believe I
cannot afford to hurt you
can you explain this are you my foe yeah
yeah that one here this is my first
video game that I have performed him
it's a whole new world for me it's quite
exciting actually I shall see this once
stop
my character is he's a very very
powerful man probably the most powerful
man and as such he doesn't need to throw
his weight around he's a man of few
words the words he speaks speak volumes
and he's ruthless he's ruthless because
he has to be my patience has its limits
do not test them she's in danger you
must find her and when I do but then I
shall give her what she deserves
the whole rise in the popularity of
fantasy now it's quite extraordinary
really it's no longer the realm of
children's entertain it is real so the
whole thing now appeals to quite
discerning adults because the special
effects are so real the worlds that are
created are so believable but it also
employs the most wonderful cinematic
techniques
what I saw of videogames ten years ago I
mean it's like a whole other world